if you have looked out the window this
morning you probably know what I'm
talking about you better be preparing
for the worst storm in history that is
what Mayor Bill de Blasio is telling New
Yorkers as the nor'-east prepares for a
light cigarette mean blizzard cuz he's
listening to the weather forecast it's
irresponsible I don't you know I a mayor
come to lure I'm gonna die come on
that's why I say that it's disaster
preparedness according to meteorologist
not just Tom Kean the storm may drop up
to three feet of snow today though mayor
de Blasio Warren quote my message to New
Yorkers is to prepare for something
worse she have seen before now is the
time to get ready for this extreme
weather Tom I have an email here from
Bloomberg meteorologist Rob Carolyn was
very good one to two feet in New York
City over two feet in some spots we're
going to be counting it in feet not
inches it's a long duration storm with
Blizzard warnings for over 30 hours yeah
not only snow impacts will be felt but
also wind impacts like coastal erosion a
brief repeat reprieve will come okay a
Wednesday before other other day pods
help me here let's go to losing here we
are storm center okay here's like
Virginia in Washington DC and it's gonna
migrate up here center point is Sally's
pizza in New Haven it's gonna dump I if
you are in at Yale right now you need to
order up pizzas I mean don't Hans come
on don't we like over do this now with
all this technology and guesstimates um
well i would say that perhaps the de
Blasio's ability to spin a message isn't
quite as good as our former mayor well I
make their appeal make that four time
we're totally unbiased you know
something I'll get put in the weather
timeout chair but i will say that it's
partly january we need to prepare for
blizzard with winds of 50 miles an hour
but I defer to mr. Carolyn of Bloomberg
surveillance and Bloomberg radio and
what was it say it again one feat in New
York one to two feet in New York City
over two feet in some spots Tom I don't
think they make snow boots I mean I'm
gonna need some over the knee right
there I've taken out my class properties
I'm looking forward to taking a shot at
getting to work skiing well I think you
know there it is and of course we hope
that everybody particularly older people
shuffling stone and of course I mean
mass
nightmare for transport over 1,800
flights already canceled but experts
always say that is the way to play this
you want to cancel more flights ahead of
road and be caught flat-footed right
what are you coming into motu I am
probably when I might have to walk in
from Chelsea you I can see it now I've
done that a couple times I walked to
work at short distance a couple times in
his gorgeous is peaceful and should use
it all did the city's quite all depends
how quickly it falls